the alarm went off before we could even
talk oh that's too bad but but at least
you have people who want to come and
visit you my family hasn't been to see
me since my trial you eat nine people
and all of a sudden they don't know who
you are anymore great
what
did you say eat people
cannibal Caleb well that's not how I
would Define myself if we're going by
what I'm most passionate about I would
say that I'm a woodworker why did you
think I was in protective custody I
don't know I guess I hoped you were
another cop wrongly convicted of crimes
you didn't commit nope I did all my
stuff and more there's tons they can't
even Trace to me the secret is eating
the evidence okay this is just
see anyone from the outside for another
three weeks and my only friend here is a
cannibal woodworker look if you really
want to talk to people on the outside
just get a cell phone yeah that'd be
great but it's illegal right there's
this guy in gen pop Romero he can
smuggle anything into this place phones
drugs big bag of hair why would you want
that you know what don't tell me the
less I know about you the better okay
let's find this Romero guy right now
everybody want to Chomp down on this
meat
Club this is scary I don't like being so
near genpa it's fine it's not like
they're all waiting for an opportunity
to kill us I'm sure some of them are
actually nice like this gentle giant
here hello Sarah what brings you to the
fence today just here to stab you if you
get too close
neat Caleb remind me not to stand too
close to the fence we'll do oh here's
Romero
so what's up you need another bag of
hair yeah
we'll talk later same order though out
whatever
hey Warden what's up what the hell are
these I found them doing a sweep of your
bunks oh uh we got those at the
commissary Picante beef you think I had
another Picante beef is the street
flavor I was being kind to you by
putting YouTube in protective custody
but if you're gonna bring Contraband
into my prison and flaunt my rules pack
your bags you're going to genpop gen pop
but my tough prison beard hasn't fully
grown in yet just give me six or seven
more years
I can't believe we're going to gen pop a
cop in a cannibal
everyone's going to be trying to kill us
I know what are we gonna do you're a
psychopath you can protect us in there
right I mean you killed and ate a bunch
of people they were children Jake weak
little children one conk on the head was
all it took damn it I can't believe I'm
friends with a cowardly cannibal oh
cream turkey you know what I could
really go for it people pot pie first of
all Jake great alliteration second of
all just because I was arrested for
cannibalism doesn't mean that all I like
to eat is people I was going to say a
chicken burrito man my cousin was so
tasty oh come on
there's Wilson I'll go make him mad when
he attacks me you film it then
afterwards he'll meet up in the bathroom
okay great what are you gonna do to get
him angry well I don't know him so I'm
not sure what buttons to push but I'm
sure if I try enough things something
will set him off
excuse me can I ask you a question go
back to your table yeah you know I would
except for oh my God that's all it took
I told you to get back to yourself
are you okay yeah What Hurts the Most is
knowing that prisoners are treated this
way every day in her penal system also
he kicked me in the wiener a bunch show
me the video I'll send it to Charleston
so you got it anonymously and then
oh my God that's all it took Caleb is
this it did you film yourself the whole
time okay look I've been in prison for
15 years I'm not good with new
technology if you want somebody to lure
a kid to a park using a lycos chat room
I'm your man look just press this button
and make it front facing come on let's
try it again hey Wilson
please tell me you're appointed in the
right direction that time yes but there
was a different issue
okay
[Music]
how'd you screw it up this time I did
and I got everything I even zoomed in
for some close-ups
oh thank God
I was so sure that something was going
to go wrong hey there Peralta
oh I'll take that phone now
hey I'm gonna bind I need your help
that's what friends are for well friends
might be a bit of a stretch I mean
you're a cannibal that ate six people
nine and a half yep worse anyway here
are my options a I keep pestering her
mayor to tell me where the drugs are he
realizes I'm a snitch then he castrates
me and kicks me to death that's not
great what's option b i back off Romero
never find out what the drugs are the
warden tells everyone I'm a snitch and
then Romero castrates me and kicks me to
death both options sound a little
castrating yeah that's what I keep
bumping up against too well you know
whenever I'm back into a corner I just
do what I do best I drive across country
Forge a new identity and then take a job
as a camp counselor oh my God Caleb
you're a genius I wouldn't say genius
they can't ran a pretty extensive
background check no not that you're past
a straight up nightmare but I need to do
what I do best be a cop work the case
and figure out where the drugs are on my
own and you tell the ward and the Warren
will bust Romero and Romero will think
I'm a snitch because he never told me
where they are all right this is gonna
be tough I'm really gonna have to thread
the needle oh I got really good at
threading needles back when you're
making your skin suit I know look I like
being friends with you but you have to
stop bringing that up but we're friends
don't let them see us blend in I gotta
tell you cop work is a lot like Hannibal
work really oh yeah they're watching
The Following
the waiting for soccer practice to end
come on man I can't believe this I'm
gonna die in here and then you're gonna
eat my castrated body I guess but it'd
be a pretty boring meal without dessert
oh my God
oh no Ramirez headed towards us and he
looks angry well he always looks angry
maybe it's not directed at you no now
he's pointing at you this is bad I know
it's bad
I wouldn't took my entire stash of soap
apparently someone told him it was blizz
and you want me to help you figure out
who it was well it was tank no it wasn't
yeah it wasn't tank it was me tank I
came clean and saved your life now you
owe me no I don't
I told you what I do to stitches oh dear
Romero Caleb what are you doing it's
okay Jake I got this Paratha is my best
friend if you want to kill him you're
gonna have to kill me first
because friendship
bro
Warden your squad busted Melanie Hawkins
you're getting out
come with me okay
wait
can I do one thing first
I wanted to say goodbye I can't believe
you saved my life I would not do it
again it really hurt nah but you did do
it and I regret it so much Caleb you're
ruining this look I just wanted to say
thank you for everything you got me
through this I'm gonna miss you ah put
it there pal
yeah
I have an idea we need to get into the
mind of a sicko and the only way to do
that
is with the help of another sicko
Jake it's so good to see you come give
me a hug I'm not gonna eat you also
don't hug me because I will try to eat
you
this is such a surprise I haven't seen
you since I transferred here how's Amy
she's great we're married and she's a
sergeant now wow yeah how's everything
here same old same-o guess who's here
Herman Herman always playing Yahtzee
knew everybody's name worship Satan did
he he never mentioned that
he wouldn't shut up about it is
exhausting well I'm Charles I'm Jake's
best friend Charles he's serving three
life sentences no need to flex so Caleb
we're tracking a serial killer and I was
thinking you could help us get inside
his head just because I ate humans
doesn't mean that I'm inhuman Jake Caleb
come on that's not what I meant I'm just
kidding I'm probably friends with a guy
online what's his deal well he's been
murdering young men and cutting out
their hearts ooh what I would never eat
a hard I stick to the normal stuff butts
and thighs one time I ate a foot but it
was nasty yeah I could see that you know
what there was some weird guy on the
Forum recently before him yeah it's a
chat room for people who like to talk
about eating human beings but definitely
won't act on it wink yeah it's hosted on
Reddit obviously anyways he showed up
from out of nowhere asking questions
about cutting out Hearts really do you
know anything else about him I've never
seen him on there before but you could
check the logs I'll approve you I'm an
admin oh you might want to switch to
incognito mode otherwise your targeted
ads will be pretty cannibal specific ah
good to know well it was good to see you
Caleb send me that info
you're a cannibal friend another visit I
wouldn't say they're friends so much as
Excel mates no that's true we're friends
he ain't kids well people are
complicated no I'll tell you one thing
you are not looking for a cannibal why
do you say that with all that blood no
self-respecting cannibal would waste all
that sauce see Charles he's a foodie
like you who are you can I see that
picture again oh man those are some nice
tools I would love to spread some ribs
using that sternum retractor but they
only sell those to hospitals wait a
minute what'd you just say I said I love
to get my little fingies and some
chesties no no no not the super gross
part surgery grade tools precise
incisions around the heart and there was
no ice at the motel because the perp was
using it for the hearts we're not
looking for a serial killer he stole the
hearts for a transplant boom we solved
it boy you'll give me a hug
for the record I'm not a cannibal
anymore my new passion is needlepoint
embroidery look at these
two parrots in love
a turtle with a monocle and a top hat
wow it's so intricate
okay you got me I was gonna eat you
that's still my thing it's even affected
my needlepoint look at this liver
a heart
but
an arm